religion is a topic that is widely
discussed today
something that people have very strong
opinions about and who often
wish to express those opinions but in
discussions about religion we often run
into very commonly recurring problems
i'm sure some of you have been in an
argument or debate where someone makes a
claim like
buddhism is peaceful a peaceful religion
or for that matter that islam is a
violent religion arguments like this pop
up
all the time people tend to have very
preconceived notions and ideas about
what a certain religion
is what it is about and how it functions
from people within certain faith
traditions or religions we also often
run into the so-called
famous no-true scotsman fallacy
for example if someone says that
christianity is peaceful
and then another person points out the
many times that
christians have promoted violence or war
or oppression
only to be counted with well those
weren't real christians
similarly in islam we often hear the
arguments that
groups like al-qaeda or the islamic
state aren't
real muslims but in statements like this
we are defining a religion based on our
own conceptions and preconceived notions
and this is pretty common in academia as
well
we often hear scholars or academics
argue that a certain religion
stands for certain things that it
functions in certain ways that it
believes in a certain thing but the
problem with
all of this is that it goes against one
of the
basic and most fundamental truths or
facts about religion generally
that religions are internally diverse
all religions are internally diverse and
consist of an almost
infinite amount of different
interpretations
schools of thought and and denominations
a second fundamental truth is that
religions are
always changing and evolving over time
so to make any kind of sweeping
generalizations about a religion is
very dangerous especially in academic
circumstances
now of course generalizations must
always be made if we are to have any
kind of discussion
if you are to talk about concepts or
anything
really with human language we have to
generalize but
it's always important to remember that
this will inevitably be
a kind of compromise so to say that
buddhism is inherently peaceful
is problematic when we consider all the
times that buddhists have committed acts
of violence for example
if we say that islam is sexist or
misogynistic
this is very problematic when we take
into considerations examples when it
isn't
and to say that there is a true version
of any of these religions
is even more problematic because that is
projecting our own perceptions and
subjective judgments onto something that
is
inherently very complicated and and
diverse and and multifaceted no one can
truly define what the true version of
any religion
is and if he or she does and that is a
question of subjective
faith and does not make it objective
truth because after all a religion is
not something that exists
out there on its own like a being of its
own a religion
is really the people that make that
religion it is the
the people that create the religion
continuously
this problem in the discourse about
religion is often referred to
as essentializing to essentialize a
religion by claiming that there is an
essential form or
version of it to paint it as a monolith
an
unchanging thing that can be
definitively defined
but this is an extremely unhelpful and
destructive way to approach religion
and one that i try very hard to
counteract with this channel
a good example to highlight this
discussion and debate
both in academic terms and in public
debate is
of course the religion of islam there is
perhaps no religion that is
more essentialized in media news
coverage or in public debates
like islam is and this is by both
non-muslims and
by muslims themselves people often it
seems feel like they have a good idea
about what islam
is we can see for example youtube videos
with titles like
what islam says on this or that subject
as if islam is this person out there who
can speak on his own when really
there is always people speaking in the
name of the religion
it is in the case of a youtube video
it's always
usually a single scholar who is
presenting his opinion
granted backed up by the opinions of
previous scholars perhaps but there's
always a counter argument there is
always someone else with another opinion
this problem is very effectively
discussed by the scholar gabrielle
maranchi in his article
sociology and anthropology of islam
where he talks about essentializing in
academia in particular
in this article we are presented with a
common view of islam as conceived by
many scholars and lay people alike
that it is somehow incapable of change
or even more prone to fundamentalism
than other religions this is one must
remember a
old kind of colonialist and orientalist
narrative regarding
muslims in particular and the middle
east in general to
paint the region as this unchanging
primitive backwards place
in relation to the west which is
changing and evolving and
enlightened so to say great scholars
like edward syed who wrote the famous
book orientalism points this out as
being one of the
main factors or main narratives that the
western
scholarship of the colonial era has put
forth
and is also one of the main issues that
we face today
in academia and generally about our
general
views and and the general portrayals
about the middle east a lot of this is
still prevalent today it is also quite
common to present a very essentializing
view of islam in
relation to the people who adhere to the
faith
as maranji points out we often tend to
believe that islam
as if that was a homogenous social
structure is the most important part
and main deciding factor in the lives
and behaviors
of muslims so if you understand what
islam
is then you'll understand all muslims
and their behavior
not only is this problematic for its
generalizing tendencies about the
religion itself
but it also fails to consider these
social political and economic factors
among many others
that shape a person's view of the world
and one's relationship to it
when some people think about the middle
east or muslims in general they
tend to think that all muslims do is
being muslims that
their whole life revolves around
practicing religion
which also exotifies them and makes them
seem different
when in reality they are often more
commonly thinking about picking up their
kids from school or
what they're going to eat for dinner now
of course
religion is infused into most aspects of
life in many of these contexts but
i think you still get my point indeed
this kind of top-down
perspective on religion can be very
dangerous and it's exactly what madanshi
criticizes
instead he proposes to view a religion
in the
reverse by saying that quote it is not
islam
that shapes muslims but rather muslims
who through
discourses practices beliefs and actions
shape islam in different times and
spaces
when talking about any religion we must
always remember that it consists of
different people all of whom have
learned their understanding of the
religion from other
people who have learned it from previous
people and so on
if one forgets the massive amount of
ways that something like
islam or christianity has manifested
itself in different
cultural and social context throughout
history and today
we run into huge problems that can only
damage both the
academic research and of course public
discussions and and opinions on religion
in general
but of course as scholar talat assad
points out
the word islam is pointing to something
as opposed to other things it does have
certain general characteristics that we
can talk about
it's true for example in this case that
the quran and
at least to most muslims the hadith
literature shape
and form the basis of the islamic
tradition
and it does have certain recurring
themes and points
i am not one in favor of a complete
relativism i believe
there are things that we can discuss or
debate
in in generalizing terms but the myriad
of ways that these
sources like the for example the quran
and the hadith have been interpreted and
understood
historically and today needs to be taken
into consideration
in any kind of conversation research or
or debate on these subjects arguably in
research and public discussions we
should quote start from muslims
rather than from islam another example
comes from the anthropologist simon
coleman in his article
recent developments in the anthropology
of religion
he also mentions how hinduism is often
judged with
india as the yardstick even though
hinduism at this point is a religion
that is widespread across the world
india is still seen as the place where
true hinduism is practiced which
creates similar problems of course what
i'm trying to do with this video is not
to overturn your
view on what a religion is completely
only a little bit
but instead to lay as a foundation for
future discussions
one of the keys to understanding
religion in an academic
way i cannot stress this enough and i'll
say it again
no religion is a homogeneous monolith no
religion
exists out there independent of our
interactions with it
religions are performed and created
continuously
by those who belong to the religion and
practice the religion
as well as those standing outside of it
the most perhaps extreme
conclusion that we can draw from this
and one that many scholars have actually
done is to say that things like well
christianity doesn't exist or
islam doesn't exist any religion like
christianity islam is only a collection
of various
cultural historical phenomena that we
place under this umbrella term and call
it
islam for example now as i stated
previously
i wouldn't go this far personally i
think if we are
it's of course an interesting
philosophical questions about concepts
and terms but it's
hardly helpful if we are to have any
kind of discussion on this subject
instead i do believe that we can
conceive of a religion in the
singular as long as we keep all the
above
aspects in mind as we do that in
theological discussions or debates about
faith from within uh religions
themselves sure we can have
discussions about who constitutes the
true version of a religion or that
say catholics are more true followers of
jesus or that sufis are heretics
but again these questions or these
statements would then be
questions of faith subjective faith and
they have no place in an academic
discussion about religion which at least
aims to be as
objective as possible if we are to look
at religions as
objectively as possible we cannot make
judgments on what teachings are more
true than
others or what denomination is closer to
some true version of the religion
as i've said we cannot even say that
there is a true version of any religion
i'll repeat again religions are
internally diverse
and are always changing and evolving
over time
no religion can escape this inevitable
fact
to say anything otherwise or to make any
kind of generalizations is to deny
this inescapable point and this is the
basis upon which
these videos are built as well
here at let's talk religion we discuss
religion from an academic
perspective this means that i always try
to avoid
making any kind of sweeping
generalizations and instead
in fact try to highlight the internal
diversity
and multifacity of different religious
traditions we have for example talked of
course a lot about islam and different
traditions within islam and
in those videos i've often consciously
tried to highlight certain figures or
certain schools of thought
that maybe does not fit with the
perceived mainstream
form of islam in part to show you that
there is always that variety
different people have understood the
same religion and conceptualized the
same religion in different
ways in different times and different
places
and this is also what you as an audience
should keep in mind as we go forward and
i make more videos
this also means that it is your duty to
if you
see me making any kind of big
generalizations to call me out on it
because we are all sensitive and subject
to these kinds of
preconceived notions and generalizations
we do it all the time even as
academics as i've said but as i also
said of course i will
have to make certain generalizations in
these videos for me to have any kind of
discussion but
again feel free to criticize me for the
kinds of essentializing and generalizing
that i will
inevitably be doing in the future
academic discussions about terms and
concepts may not be the most
exciting topic to talk about in these
videos but
it is a very important part a very
important aspect that
we need to discuss that we need to keep
in mind if we want to have a fruitful
discussion going forward now i do have
some
less dry videos coming in the near
future
with the arrival of october the month of
october we will celebrate this
most spooky month of the year with some
videos about more
darker and more mysterious aspects of
different religions
i also have a very exciting
collaboration that i'm working on with
another youtube channel that i will
uh announce soon and i'm also working on
videos about alder rosali
and eben rust so stay tuned for all of
that
as always i would like to thank my
patrons and especially some of the more
recent arrivals including harith
zedd orchard siawish rahman and
me excuse me i'm going to butcher your
name but mikhail
stankievich if you want to support this
channel and my
work please consider becoming a patron
yourself i will leave a link to that
page in the description
otherwise you can as always just like
the video and if you aren't subscribed
then feel free to do that as well
and don't forget to leave a comment so
we can continue this
discussion there i'll see you next time
[Music]
you